[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
We're thrilled
to have you with us
for the next 45 minutes
or so to talk about Google's
serverless Compute options.
Which you can all
use today and some
you'll be able to use
in the near future.
My name is Alexis.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: And
my name is Guillaume.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: And we
will cover Cloud
Functions, App Engine.
With all the new, exciting
features some of you
have heard of already, maybe,
that were announced yesterday,
as well as in this
morning's keynote.
We will also highlight
a multiservice demo
spanning across multiple
products, multiple languages.
And finally, we'll have
a glimpse at the future
of serverless containers.
Now, let's get started.
But first, what is
important for your company?
What do you do as a
developer for your company?
Well, hopefully you create
applications and functionality
that matters to your users.
And to do that, if you were
to deploy your application
on your own
infrastructure, you would
have to deal with a number
of things, such as selecting
that infrastructure, buying
the hardware potentially,
configuring the
operating system,
deciding whether you're going
to use containers or not,
defining what kind of
storage strategy you have,
and so forth-- configuring
the network, the load
balancing, the logging,
and all of these things.
So building a pipeline
of continuous integration
is maybe something else
you need to take care of.
And on top of that,
the company needs
to worry about security
patches-- maintaining
everything in good shape.
And all of these
operational tasks
are very important things.
And you need to do all
of these before you
can start writing any code.
So let me introduce you to
Google's new serverless data
center.
Now, obviously, this is--
you all know this.
The joke never gets
old, but serverless
does involve servers--
actually, lots of servers.
Besides this is a really
old building, way too
dirty to be a data center.
The key here, though,
is that as a developer
you do not need to
manage the servers.
You do not need to install
OS updates, patches.
You do not need to set up
monitoring, auto scaling,
or configure any kind
of load balancing.
We offer to do it for you.
So here's our little
attempt to define serverless
in two different ways.
The first one is really
an operational model.
And I think most people
here are familiar with that.
You don't manage the servers.
You don't even see them.
You don't see the
abstraction of a server.
You're higher up the stack.
The other aspect of that is,
of course, that it auto scales.
If you have traffic,
we will make
sure we have enough resources
to serve that traffic.
And, of course, we
will have the ability
to scale from zero
to almost infinity.
And we will bill you for that--
that is also part of the deal.
So you will pay for the usage.
No usage, no bill.
That's the other part.
Now, second we believe it's
also a programming paradigm.
One would say, a cloud
in the native way
of developing applications.
Instead of shipping code that
bundles a lot of libraries
as part of the
application, instead you
consume services that are
otherwise exposed as such.
And you do expose maybe
yourself a few functionalities
as services.
So instead of having a
very tightly coupled,
intertwined set of features,
your application has services.
And maybe this is
event-driven, and rather
than having synchronous
calls between services,
you're also able to take in
asynchronous event-driven
calls.
Now, serverless,
as you can see, is
way more than just
functions-- bits
of code running in the cloud.
It can be Compute.
We'll definitely talk
about that today.
But it spans across many other
things, such as, database--
where you did not see
the concept of a server,
all you want is a
persistent service,
that's all you really needed--
data warehousing, analytics,
data processing and ETL,
or even machine
learning training
that can be done without having
to set up any sort of cluster
and, of course, without
having to resize or manage
those clusters.
So Compute on its
own is not enough.
You need all of those.
But let's focus on
Compute for a moment.
serverless end on
GCP, of course,
you can map all of these things
to lots of different products
that we have, but focus
on Cloud Functions and App
Engine, which are the two
products that we have.
Both of them are
generally available,
as you'll see in a moment.
But we will focus
on those while using
some of the other services.
We will be using Cloud Pub/Sub,
a highly scalable messaging
system that can be used
to build some really
scalable applications.
We will use Cloud Datastore.
We will not use
BigQuery, although this
is an amazing product
which basically takes
your data and your queries and
returns Insights results to you
SQL queries in interactive time
without having to understand
how this is all deployed.
So again, we're in
the serverless realm.
But let's go back to Compute,
Cloud Functions, and App
Engine.
So Cloud Functions is
functions as a service,
if you are into acronyms.
And App Engine is
platform as a service,
for those old enough to
remember that acronym.
So why two?
Why have two products?
Well, let's find out.
The great things about
choice is that it
enables you to adapt to
different requirements
that you might have.
But the other side
of it is, of course,
that you need to understand what
kind of choice you're making,
and what the drawbacks might be.
So let's take a moment to
review both products as they're
available to you today.
So let's probably start with
Functions and Guillaume.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Thank you.
All right.
So our applications,
our infrastructure,
is becoming more and
more event-driven.
So we're interested
in events that
are being emitted by some kind
of service, application, API,
et cetera, that are
intercepted, here, in our case,
by Cloud Functions, which is
going to respond to events.
Inside our function, we
can also trigger new events
or invoke other services,
APIs, store some data
in Cloud Datastore, a file
in Cloud Storage, et cetera.
The unit of work
for Cloud Functions
is, as the name
implies, a function.
So a function, it's a small
unit of work with a fine grain
small focus.
There are two ways to
trigger your function, so
either synchronous calls with
HTTP. or just a mere HTTP.
or get, or post, or et cetera,
or a more asynchronous events.
So, for example,
new files stored
in Cloud Storage
or a new message
on a Pub/Sub topic which
can trigger your function.
Some examples of where you can
use functions-- so typically,
one example I'm going to take
with the HTTP call, that's
if you're building or
chat bot, for example,
with Dialogflow for
the Google Assistant.
You can define a WebHook
within the Dialogflow UI,
to say, OK, when there's
some need for business logic,
for fetching some data or
something from the chat bot,
then call this function.
Similarly, if you're using
GitHub for your source code,
there are commit
hooks which allow
you to be notified when
there's a new pull requests,
when there's a new commit
coming up in your source tree.
So that's for the
synchronous calls with HTTP.
But another example, and
that's what we're also
going to use in the demo later
on, for example, with pictures
being uploaded to Cloud Storage.
So you want to create thumbnails
you want to crop the picture
or do something
with that picture
once it's stored in
Storage, your function
is notified-- it is triggered.
In the demo, as you
shall see, we're
going to use the newly
announced, Cloud Scheduler.
So whenever, at regular
intervals of time--
let's say, in my case,
I'm using Cloud Scheduler
for triggering an event every
one minute-- every minute.
So I'm going to get a little
message about different ways
of using the Cloud Schedule.
But in my case, I'm going to use
the Pub/Sub mechanism or a pipe
to get the message to
trigger one of my functions.
And all that, obviously-- oh,
yeah, another example that it
was interesting that
was given yesterday,
I think, by Oren Teich,
that was, for example,
with Stackdriver you can create
alerts when something happens.
For example, you can see
by looking through the logs
that something happens
that is unusual,
you could also specify that
the alert pings your function.
So that's an
interesting use case
for further automating
your infrastructure,
your whole project.
So from a developer
perspective, what
do you deploy is really
just code basically.
So as a developer,
you just focus--
and who's a developer
in the audience?
Yeah, quite a few hands.
Nice.
So if you were a developer,
you focused on your code
and you don't necessarily
want, upfront,
in particular, to have
to think about servers,
about creating
clusters, about managing
those servers, or the
provisioning, or all
that stuff.
Also, at some point, if your
application is very successful,
you're going to need
to be able to scale.
And, well, it's not always
easy to scale your architecture
to cope with the incoming
traffic and traffic spikes.
But also, a nice aspect
of serverless, it's auto
scaling down.
So from zero to n, that's nice.
But also, from n back
to 1 or 0, that's
also something that's
important to do.
And, of course, you don't want
to pay for nothing, basically.
So if your code is not running,
you're not going to be billed.
So, yeah.
Pay only for what
you use, right?
From your functions-- so I
mentioned a few triggers,
Cloud Storage,
Pub/Sub, et cetera.
But from your functions you can
call all the services you want.
So you have, at your
disposal, things
like virus kind of databases,
data store, spanner, BigTable,
et cetera.
You have access to all the
machine learning APIs--
that's what we're going to do
with the demo with the Vision
API.
You take advantage of all
the logging capabilities,
error reporting, of Stackdriver.
So it's one big bag
of things that you
can take advantage of within
the code of your functions.
So as you learned
about yesterday,
Cloud Functions is generally
available, with a 99.5% service
level agreement.
It's also available
across different regions.
Four regions-- two in the US,
one in Europe, one in Asia.
What's interesting to know as
well is that your functions,
they don't have to all
be in one single region.
But you can have
functions in Europe.
function in the US, within
the same GCP project.
So if you want to have functions
that are closer to your users,
you can do that.
You have modern runtimes.
So the newly announced
runtimes, node 8
for using things
like async await
to make your code easier
to read when handling
the promises, et cetera.
Python 3.7-- so that's the
very latest and greatest Python
with a thin Flask framework
for defining your functions.
And there are also more
languages coming soon.
In terms of the coming
features, I already
mentioned all the
error reporting,
logging capabilities,
which is always nice
when you're
developing debugging,
and if you have got
some prediction issues
you want to trace back
what actually happened.
A very important aspect,
that's the built-in dependency
resolution in the Cloud.
So you don't have
to, for example,
when you use node modules,
some may require some libraries
or need to be compiled because
there is some native code.
So you don't have to
cross-compile things locally,
upload the modules,
and things like that.
It's really in the cloud that
this dependency resolution
and build is being done.
So it's one thing less to
think about-- really just
focus on defining
your dependencies
and writing your code.
I think there was
something else.
Oh, yeah, when I was
mentioning dependencies,
your French friends are
actually running on uBuntu image
under the hood, and there
are several libraries
that are already pre-installed.
So, for example, things like
FFmpeg for dealing with videos,
ImageMagick if you want to do
some stuff with your pictures.
But you also have all the set
of libraries that are required
to run Chrome in headless mode.
So, for example, if you
want to have a function that
takes screenshots or generates
PDFs from a particular web
page, if you want to do some
kind of end-to-end testing
where your function actually
controls a browser, Chrome
Headless browser, you
can do that easily
with Cloud Functions today.
So the newest capabilities that
have been announced as well.
That's the VPC and VPN access.
So you can say, when you
deploy your function,
that your function is tied
to a particular VPN network.
So what that means is
that, let's say you already
have some VMs running
on Compute Engine,
your function is able
to access those VMs
and chat with those VMs.
So it's not two
separate worlds anymore.
In addition to that,
related to security,
you have also IM role binding.
So if you want to
say, OK, this function
should be called only by
that role or et cetera,
this is now possible.
So instead of having
a function that
is publicly available in the
cloud via HTTP, for example,
you have finer grain control
now in terms of secure access.
We also introduced
scaling controls.
So it's especially for
limiting, actually,
the number of instances of
one particular function.
So this can be useful for things
like cost control, of course.
But also, let's say you have a
function that calls a database,
instead of overloading
the database with too many
connections, if you know you
cannot have more than 100
connections, you can say, OK,
I don't want more than 100
functions to be running to
avoid the problem of draining
the connections and having
connections issue with
your database.
Before it was GA--
well, no, it is already GA.
it's not yet.
So all this stuff, except
environment variables,
which are already
available, this stuff
is coming the end of the year.
So what I wanted to say about
the Cloud SQL direct connect
is that so far, and
as of today, you
had to go through the
internet if you wanted
to access a Cloud SQL instance.
But now with the upcoming Direct
SQL, Direct Connect Cloud SQL--
oh, I mixed the
words, you get it--
you are able to go
through the Google network
directly without going
outside through the internet
to get access to your database.
Last but not least,
environment variables--
so with functions, you're able
to define your environment
variables.
For example, if
you want to define
different kind of environments,
prot, dev, staging,
or if you have any pieces
of configuration that
shouldn't really be stored
in your source code,
in your source tree,
and your repository,
it can be passed as
environment variables.
And we'll see an
example in the demo
where I am actually using
environment variables.
All right, that's
about it for functions.
Let's see a bit more
about App Engine.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Yep.
Let's switch gears and
talk about App Engine.
Actually, no, the demo will
come in just a little bit later.
Can we go back to slides?
So the fundamental difference
with Cloud Functions
here is, well, in the name.
The unit of computing of
deployment, if you will,
here, is an app.
So an app, obviously, is
coarser grain than a function.
It might be interesting if
you're moving from a monolith
to the cloud--
I mean moving from a monolith
to function-based programming,
and full microservices
might be a bridge
too far for many people.
Instead, App Engine
may be a better fit.
And still in the
realm of serverless
where we take care of
a lot of things for you
as we already said.
But as we will see, you
are still, in App Engine,
able to structure your code.
And that, we believe,
is important.
So the unit is the application,
the trigger is HTTP,
and it's best used
for migrating,
we believe, existing
applications, and, generally
speaking, for HTTP services.
Most developers will have
preferred languages--
I know I do--
and expect to use them
with no constraints.
Like, don't tell me to
use that proprietary PI.
Don't tell me you cannot
use that set of libraries.
I would like to be able to
use this in what we call
idiomatic ways,
which is any habit
that I have I would like to be
able to take this to the Cloud.
We'll come back to this.
This is really important.
To deploy your
application, there's
really no configuration needed.
It's a G cloud or SDK
command line, app deploy.
And it will look at your
artifacts, your application,
and it will deploy this.
And once deployed,
similar as with functions,
you'll be able to auto
scale from zero to a lot,
and back to zero.
Billing is done accordingly.
No traffic, no cost.
So App Engine today--
App Engine is 10 years old.
So that's a decade
of a lot of things.
And some of you might have seen
App Engine not evolve quite
a bit for the last few years.
And the reason for that is that
the team has been hard at work
on a new infrastructure and
a new sandbox technology.
Which enables a lot
of things, security
being the most
important, but for you
developers there are a few
things coming with that as
well.
So first of all, we have,
generally available, the Java 8
runtime, which enables not only
Java 8 and all the features
that come with it, such as
lambda expressions, pipeline
streams, but also all the
languages running on the JVM,
such as Scala, Kotlin, Groovy.
So that is really something
that a lot of people use.
The second thing is, just as
with functions, we support
Node 8, currently in beta.
In the next 30 days you will
have access to Python and PHP
with very modern and
recent versions as well.
And more features, more
languages, more updates
are coming soon.
We also have a new
instance scheduler,
that logic that says how
many, and how quickly,
and how often I need to
spin up new instances,
and what is the logic behind
scaling down, which is really,
I would think, the secret sauce
behind App Engine, is new.
And that was released
a couple of months ago.
We believe its more
predictable-- so you
understand why it's doing
the things it's doing.
It offers better utilization
with less cold starts--
so when you hit an instance
that is hit for the first time
there's less of that.
And it offers new
settings to balance
costs versus performance.
And we believe we have
faster deployments, which
is always important.
We do a lot of things
when we deploy.
We're deploying
requires a cluster.
I mean the cluster is there,
you just don't see it.
So we need to do a lot
of checks before we
can say that the app
is live and running.
And we believe we
can do that better.
And if you're in the
health care industry,
you'll be happy to know that
as of, again, a few months ago,
we are now HIPAA compliant.
Now, let's go back
to this idiomatic way
of developing apps.
We call this the second
generation idiomatic runtimes.
And this is enabled by a
technology called gVisor.
Anybody has heard of
gVisor here before?
Just a few people.
This is really cool technology.
You don't have to really
understand how it works,
you can just reap the benefits.
It is an open source
technology that we've
announced at the last
CubeCon-- so a few months ago.
It is a new sandbox
technology which
offers this idiomatic
developer experience.
You can use any API, any
library that you want,
and it should just work.
Any module from the
official Node.js package
manager such as headless Chrome,
which Guillaume mentioned,
any Java jar library,
any Python library.
You do not need to change
your code and the way
it uses those libraries.
At most you should have
to add maybe some metadata
to your application in the
form of some YAML or XML, just
to describe it, to give
it a version number,
and that's really it.
Note, by the way, that
everything I'm describing here,
all the benefits
gVisor, is something
we're using both in Cloud
Functions and in App Engine.
Now, this is not a
new feature, but I
think it's important we
spend a minute on it.
App Engine, because
application can
have multiple distinct
layers or modules,
say a front-end, some business
logic, some data access layers,
some admin piece, as
you'll see in the demo,
it's interesting
to be able to split
your application in different
modules or services.
In App Engine you can
do that, of course.
Each service has a version.
Potentially, all those
versions, by the way,
are active at the same time.
And you'll see why
that could be useful.
And each version can
be scaled independently
from the other one.
You probably don't have the same
scaling needs for some admin
back-end with two
people accessing it,
and the front-end, which
is for the world to use.
So we believe it's a great
fit for microservices.
Each service can also be
written in a different language.
There's really no
constraints there.
And if that makes sense
for you, you can certainly
take advantage of that.
But maybe more powerful,
this built-in feature,
multiple services
active at the same time,
enables things such as service
level upgrades, A/B testing,
canary releases, all
of that with something
we call traffic splitting.
Traffic splitting is not
a new feature either,
but it proves to be
extremely powerful,
and I would say trivial,
or very easy, to enable.
Once you've given a
module, a service, a name,
which is free-form.
You could call it 1235.
You could call it beta, green,
red, blue, whatever you'd like.
You do this in a config file.
Once you have that, you can
start addressing and sending
parts of the traffic
to a new version.
And this is based on IP address
on cookie, or completely
at random.
So this allows you to do
something like A/B testing.
Maybe you will be
offering shipping costs
to 50% of your users, or you'll
be offering an general discount
on your goods to the
other 50%, and you'll
see which one works best.
So that's something you can do.
And of course you can also
do canary releases-- deploy
a new app to a few percentage of
your users, see how it behaves,
and as you increase confidence
and you see no errors,
you start sending more
load, more traffic,
and eventually you move
the entire traffic to it.
Or you go back
because you've found
something that's really bad.
No code changes,
no config changes
in terms of changing
any XML or YAML file.
This is all done very
simply from the command line
or from the UI.
And, of course,
traces and logs can
be used to filter by version.
And this is where you
can see that something
is going good, or not so good
and you might need to rollback.
So for those of
you that have been
using App Engine
for several years,
you might have seen that
a number of App Engine's
specific features have graduated
into a standalone product.
The most famous of them
has been Datastore.
Which might seem crazy,
but back in the days
you had to use App Engine to
access this amazing no SQL
back-end that we have.
There are many more services
that we'd like to point out,
but there's two that
we like to point out.
They are fairly new.
And that can be used from App
Engine, from Cloud Functions,
or maybe even if you're
still running on a VM
on Compute Engine,
that you can use
and that are now
standalone GCP product.
The first one is
called Cloud Tasks,
which will soon be in beta.
I think the official thing
is in the next 30 days.
So stay tuned.
Initially, this was an
App Engine feature--
task queues.
And it's coming
soon as a standalone
and fully managed service.
It will take care of
executing, dispatching,
and delivering a large
number of distributed tasks.
Using this, you can
perform work asynchronously
outside of the user requests,
and process requests
in batches.
So this is a great way to
scale your architecture.
The main architectural
benefit here
is really to be able to decouple
the user requests from scaling
all those microservices.
In the beta release
you'll support
for Python, Java, and Node.
And you'll be able to set things
such as rate limits, retry,
configs.
And this will be, I
believe, something
that's fairly useful for
building scalable microservices
architectures.
Next is Google Cloud Scheduler.
Well, this is really
chron in the cloud.
Nothing super fancy, but this is
something that a lot of people
need.
And we believe that what we have
now with Cloud Scheduler, which
we'll show briefly in
the demo, is the ability
to configure the
regularly scheduled tasks
and have them operate at
those regular intervals.
So common use cases are,
being able to send an email
reports on a daily basis, maybe
update some cache data every 10
minutes, or update some
summary information every hour.
This is also probably
the most elegant solution
to the frequently requested
feature of invoking functions
at regular intervals.
So again, this is not
tied to a product,
this is a product
of it's own, and can
be used to trigger jobs
and manage all of them
in one place, rather than
have and reinvent this chron
feature in different parts
of your architecture.
And, of course, you can hit
HTTP endpoints, Pun/Sub topic,
or relative URL handlers
to hit App Engine apps.
And this will be made
available in the next 30 days.
Now, before I hand it over
to Guillaume for the demo,
we will be walking
through some slides
to explain what we built
with all the technology
that we've just discussed.
And hopefully, this will
be interesting to you.
Over to you, Guillaume.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Thank you.
So I decided to create a little
picture sharing application.
So if you want to try it you can
go to pic-a-daily.appspot.com.
So with this application you
can take pictures of stuff
around you.
So you can feel free to
create a picture right away.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Selfies.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE:
Selfies, whatever.
As you can see,
there's the picture,
there's a little color around
it, that's the main color--
the dominant color
of the picture.
We'll see why this is
important later on.
We also see tags.
This is actually
what the Vision API
tells me, OK, in that picture I
see, I don't know, what is it?
Interior, cushion,
furniture, bed, et cetera.
So if you click on the pink
camera button, you can do--
I'll do it later on.
I'll take a picture
of myself on stage.
So you can choose
the camera you want.
And after that there's also the
little tags icon in the menu
and the icons on the top.
You can also have a look
at the most frequent tags,
most frequent labels that
have been recognized.
So that's the first
App Engine service.
And I also have another service,
which is our admin back-end.
So basically just for
Alex and myself to see.
So you can see two tabs
published unfiltered,
because with the
Vision API I'm checking
that nobody uploaded something
weird, and I can publish stuff.
So this is the main ideas
in that little demo.
So what's happening?
So a user takes a picture via
the web page via JavaScript,
the picture is sent to
the main App Engine,
so the front end, which
defines a web API in where
I can post my picture.
When that picture is
taken and sent to my app,
we are going to store that
picture in Cloud Storage.
And before I mention what
happens to the picture,
we also add some metadata,
like the URL, basically,
of the name of the
picture in the Datastore.
When that picture
arrives on Cloud Storage
a function is triggered.
This function is going to call
the Vision API to get labels--
so that's the tags you
see below the pictures--
to get the color,
the dominant color--
that's why the pictures were
framed with some colors.
And we're also using the filter,
the save search annotation,
which tells you if
the content contains
adult, racy, violent,
medical content,
and that kind of stuff.
When the Vision API
answers the request,
the function actually adds
metadata in the datastore--
so again, the labels,
color, filters, et cetera--
in the entry we created when
we uploaded the picture.
So that's one thing.
So if you remember the popular
tags page, in the popular tags,
so the way I implemented it, it
was a bit of an afterthought.
I'm actually going
through all the metadata
stored in datastores.
So I'm going through all the
other lines in my data store.
So it's not the most
efficient way to do that.
So it's an expensive query
which takes time to run.
Actually, for the few hundred
or thousands of pictures
that I have, it's pretty fast.
But let's imagine I've
got millions of pictures,
and if I have to go
through all those pictures,
the query might take a
little bit more time.
So instead, what I'm doing
is that I'm taking actually
a snapshot of the most frequent
pictures that I'm storing again
in datastore.
So that way I don't have
to do the costly operation,
I just have to do a simple read
operation in the datastore,
rather than going
through all the results.
So App Engine for the front-end,
two functions in Node.js.
And we have a second
service in App Engine,
which is the admin interface.
So let's see that's
on the demo machine.
So as everybody
knows the internet
has been invented for sharing
pictures and videos of cats.
So let me introduce you
to Shoecat, she's called.
It's a one month and a
half old, little baby
cat-- a little kitty.
So here I am looking
at the cat tag.
Yeah, I love my cat, so I
have a few pictures of my cat,
all right?
You can see the latest
pictures-- yeah,
thank you for uploading
some pictures.
Yeah, that's cool.
Thanks-- oops--
thanks a lot for that.
I can also take one--
Alex, come, come, come.
OK.
So that was the
new picture button.
And here you can all see
the tags, or the most
frequent tags, I
don't know which one I
could have a look at--
like flowers.
There are a few flowers
that have been uploaded.
Well, that's from my garden.
Oh, and there's your
tennis racket somewhere.
I think it's in
recreation, or fun perhaps.
I don't remember where it is.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Oh, that's fun!
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Yeah.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
That's cool.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: That's fun.
OK. that's cool.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, we were very
serious earlier.
All right
So, yeah.
That's a quick introduction
to this application.
So thanks for sharing
your own pictures.
And feel free to add
additional pictures later on.
Oh, yeah.
I need to show you the
admin interface as well.
So here-- there shouldn't be--
where is it?
There are some broken
links-- that's strange.
Now, interestingly, some of your
pictures have been filtered.
This one is racy,
I don't know why.
Or like this one, it
almost looks like blurred--
so there's violence.
But it's actually my dessert.
I'm sorry.
That's not blood.
[LAUGHTER]
So sometimes the Vision API--
it could be blood, but
it's just some strawberry
or something-- some jam.
So let's have a look at how
this has been implemented.
So here I'm going to show you--
first, I'll start with the
Java app, which is the main app
that you are using.
So I used a small framework
called Spark Java, which is
a very lightweight framework.
So that's nice for App Engine.
I have a few routes.
So this is the root
of the website.
I have tags.
So, for example, when I
was navigating via tags,
like black phone, whatever.
So you can see in the
URL tags, slash black.
So this is tags colon tag.
There's a [INAUDIBLE].
I could have created another
service for that one actually.
The pure API part which is not
for the visual web front-end,
but which is used by the
admin API, as well as by the--
so it's view.js
JavaScript application
which calls this API part.
So there's a post request
here, for example.
So slash API slash pictures,
when you post there you
can post the picture.
So when I'm doing
that, you can see
that I'm creating a new
entry in the datastore.
That's where I'm going to store
the metadata from my picture.
And I'm also using the cloud
storage, getting the bucket
and adding a new
file in my bucket.
And then I return some
images and content.
Perhaps I can show you one more.
So this one, that's
the one which
gets all the other
pictures, basically.
So I've got a query, I
go over the picture kind,
I order by the most
recent pictures.
I just want see the top 20.
And then I'm returning.
So I didn't fully
implement pagination,
but I was using the cursor
to be able to do pagination.
But that's for the next
version of my startup
off picture sharing.
And then I'm returning
the JSON payload
thanks to the JSON library.
So this is basically what
the API and front-end code
looks like.
Perhaps in the
resources, for example,
I could also show you this one.
That's the view.js code which,
thanks to the Fetch API,
calls my back-end, so slash API,
slash pictures, potentially,
with a tag.
And then the JavaScript code
updates the page, single page
app style, to show the
pictures, especially when
I navigate from text to text.
So that's the main app here.
Now, let's have a quick
look at the admin service.
So the admin service--
so initially I when I wanted
to tweak the metadata,
or delete a picture,
or unpublish or publish
a particular picture, I
was going through the Cloud
console, and go
through the console
just to do my little updates.
But as I was a bit in a
rush, one of our colleagues,
[INAUDIBLE],, who's a Go
developer, told me, hey,
by the way, I can do a little
admin front-end for you
if you want.
So he created a Go
application-- a Go App Engine
application-- with some jQuery.
And I styled it
in the same style
of the rest of the application.
And so you can see
the published picture.
And it's interesting, because
there's a bug that wasn't there
this morning.
I don't know why.
And as you could
see, you can zoom in,
you can see the reasons
why something was filtered,
and I can potentially delete.
So, for example, I don't
know, I can delete this one.
Well, you get the idea.
So this one, pictures.go.
So that's my second module.
There are a few routes
that have been defined
to get the pictures, do the
filtering, deleting pictures,
there's a struct to define the
structure of the data that's
in the datastore, creating
keys for the datastore.
And let's have a look, let's
say, at the list of pictures.
So again, we're doing a
query on all the pictures,
defining some order--
filtered, processes, by
timestamp, et cetera.
So it's just some plain Go code.
And as you remember, when you
see here all the little tags,
they are actually coming
from the Vision API.
So when the picture is
uploading on Cloud Storage,
I'm triggering the
function that I'm
going to show you right now.
So we saw some Java,
we saw some Go.
So now, let's have a look at
some JavaScript with Node.
So here-- and we're
receiving an event.
The event is actually, in
terms of the data that's
stored in that event object,
it contains the filename
of the picture and the bucket
in which this picture is stored.
So what I'm doing
there is that I'm
going to prepare query
for the Vision API.
So I will enable detection.
I want the image
properties to be
able to get the dominant color,
safe search for filtering.
I'm calling the API here.
Once I get the API
call is successful,
I get through the JSON to
find the right information.
And then I'm going
to store some updates
to the metadata for the file.
So I'm going to store the main
color, the labels, et cetera,
back into the datastore,
And the other one--
so as I said, computing
the most frequent tags
is an expensive operation.
So I decided to do some
snapshots once every minute.
So I defined a crumb of,
well, once every minute,
please call my function.
So this is the second
function, which is here.
So first of all,
notice that I used
the new feature,
environment variables, here.
So I can access the
environment variable
by using process dot nth dot
the name of my environment
variable.
So I have a default
value, just in case
it's not passed as parameters.
But if you look at
the functions here
in the console, popular
tags, which is here,
you can see down there,
environment variables,
API endpoint, I defined
the URL of the endpoint.
All right?
What am I doing here?
So I'm not really interested
in any data from the events,
because it's really
just once every minute.
So there's no data
that I actually need.
And then I'm doing the
frequency calculation
and storing the most frequent
tags in the datastore again.
So that's about it for the code.
So again, you see
previously there
were some errors when I was
developing those functions.
You can see the
actual usage there.
So there are really
two functions--
popular tags, which is
a message via a topic,
Cloud Scheduler pushes a
message on the Cloud Pub/Sub.
And here there's a bucket.
That's the bucket where
I stored my pictures.
And I'd like to
show you two things.
So this morning, I did a load.
So it was-- yeah, this
morning, so it's a bit small.
But if you remember,
in the abstract,
we said, yea, scale
from 0 to 1,000.
So I did.
I created some load
injectors to be
able to try to go up to 1,000.
So I can't zoom in
because it's gone,
but I managed to go up
to 938 instances created
in just a couple of minutes by
adding more load and more load
injectors.
And at some point, I really
had like almost 600 instances
running.
And the other thing
I wanted to mention,
a feature that I
particularly like,
when you look at the services--
the version, sorry.
I have two versions for
my application here.
So this is the normal version.
But I also have a gray version.
So if I want to do some A/B
testing to see if users prefer
a gray background instead of
white, here in the console,
I can easily do split
traffic at random.
I want to add a new version.
And for example, I
want the gray version
to get a bit of traffic.
So I'm updating those settings,
or you can do it with G Cloud
to come in line.
And once in a while you should
see a different background.
White, white, white.
Ahh.
Gray at some point?
Yeah, gray at some point.
So it's fairly easy to
do traffic splitting
for A/B testing,
canary releases,
green-blue
deployments, and so on.
All right, that's it.
Let's switch back to the slides.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Thank you, Guillaume.
So let's recap quickly
what we've seen.
We've seen an
application deployed
across Cloud Functions
and App Engine,
with multiple functions written
in JavaScript with Node,
and one applique App Engine
app using multiple services.
All of this, including
idiomatic language
runtime, such as
Node, obviously,
for the functions, Java 8,
and Go for the admin part.
We've used multiple
GCP services, again,
both Functions and App Engine.
The reason you want
to use those services
is that you're able to
access the power of GCP.
We used the Vision API, which
is one of the main pieces that
gets you all those tags.
But we've used a number of
additional services as well.
And things that we
haven't shown too much,
but we have a reference
to in other talks
that we encourage to go
to, is how Stackdriver
aggregates all the logs from all
the parts of your application
and provides you with very
interesting information,
both for developing and for
managing the application.
Giving away
responsibility of scaling
the application doesn't mean
giving away all the ops job
and keeping you from seeing
what's really Happening--
Quite the opposite, in fact.
And of course, this
was fully serverless.
No server was
harmed in this demo.
Now, what you've
seen is that we're
able to take your
artifacts, whether they
come in the form of a function,
a collection of functions,
an app with one or multiple
modules, and that's great.
And we do this, and we
take those artifacts
and we auto scale them,
and it's a per use model.
Now, increasingly people
are packaging their code
into containers for
various reasons.
So what if we were able to offer
you, the developer, the choice
of taking not just functions
or apps as deployment units,
but also containers
and still offer
that serverless operational
model with auto scalability
and pay per use?
So here are a couple
of upcoming options
that we're excited
to share with you
and that were
announced and covered
this morning in the keynote.
The first one is called
serverless containers.
Imagine we have
containers that are
stateless that comply to some
requests response signature.
The promise here of
serverless containers
is to offer that
auto scalability,
health checks for applications
packaged in those containers
with arbitrary libraries.
So imagine a random
or any Docker file
with any base image, an
arbitrary set of libraries
or language runtime, be able
to deploy those with a command
that you are familiar with,
G Cloud Functions deploy,
and simply adding this
option of pointing
to that particular
container that,
again, needs to be stateless.
Well, if you do
that, our job will
be to provide you that
serverless environment where
we auto scale, and do
all the health checks,
and all the monitoring
that is required.
No servers, and still pay
only while the code runs.
If you'd like to sign up for
the EAP that is coming before
the end of this year
g.co/serverlesscontainers.
And this is G Cloud
Functions deploy.
Now, a second option is the
serverless add-on for GKE.
And this was also
discussed this morning.
So whether we're talking
GKE, which we know and love
in Google Cloud Platform,
or the GKE on-prem, which
was just announced as
well, here what we have is
a one-step install
technology built on Knative.
If you haven't seen Knative, you
probably want to look at this.
It's an open source
project that's
helping make those artifacts
that you deploy portable.
And in this case,
we used this, and we
built the serverless add-on
on for GKE on Knative.
And what it allows
is for you to deploy,
this time with a new
artifact, the deploy with not
only the container but also
the Kubernetes cluster,
whether it's on-prem or GKE,
that you would like to target.
And the reason we'd
like to do this,
or to offer this
as an option, is
if you were to reuse an
infrastructure that you already
have, that you already know.
Or maybe you would like to
have some custom VM sizes
in that GKE cluster or GPUs.
So with all those reasons we
have yet another option for you
to deploy serverless
workloads, this time on GKE.
So it's time to
scale down to zero.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Yep.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: So
Guillaume want to thank you.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Thank you.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: But
we need quickly to conclude.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: So whenever
you've got small units of code
that you need in an
event-driven approach,
Functions are
definitely a great fit
for bigger business logic,
long running web apps, web API,
or back-ends.
App Engine is really awesome
and scales Snapchat-style,
and serverless add-on for when
you need a more portability,
more control on where
you are actually running,
or if you need special
resources like GPUs,
or that kind of stuff.
So it's up to you.
And you can mix
everything together.
There are some more
sessions happening tomorrow.
So thanks again for your
attention, and see you soon.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]